in this day and age using emerging
technology is a major key to success so
thanks to smg media group the sponsors
of this next segment we get to learn
from engineer influencer and
entrepreneur jess jeff ivan so welcome
to the show jeff
hey good afternoon how are you i'm good
how are you
fantastic for a friday afternoon ready
to get off the weekend we are almost
there we are almost there happy friday
now you're with riverpoint technology so
just tell us about what you guys do in
general yeah yeah we are a digital
service provider which simply means we
work with companies supporting their
information technology initiatives
around things like digital
transformation to help them
use new technology to help better
service their customers
it's nothing more than that no i feel
like you know i should
know what this means but for anybody who
doesn't know what this means what is
digital transformation exactly
yeah so anybody that runs in technology
knows we love our buzzwords so we we
always have some catchphrase that's a
popular one
but digital transformation is nothing
more than companies bringing new
services getting away from manual things
to
modern services like you know how many
you know how many people really call the
pizza shop to order a pizza though they
do it through an app or you know i do
curbside pickup or right or i order
clothes through my local store and go do
curbside pickup
or think about it like in terms of a
casino for las vegas right like in terms
of like getting real-time rewards or
being able to gamble online through an
application those are all
digital
ways of using new technology to bring
new applications to market and that's
really all digital transformation is
uh for companies that are uh bringing
new services and better experiences for
their customers okay that's that was a
great explanation it's you know evolving
with the times i guess you could say and
you have a new book to help people
understand this further it's called
value creation technology now explain
that concept
yeah so it's something just uh it's a
concept that we created over the years
of working with companies of all sizes
um and you know companies that use
technology quite often and those that
don't but it's really a a boiled down
version of what works and what doesn't
work so it's just you know companies
don't have a lot of time to focus on
you know just try what we call science
experiments they have a business to run
they got to keep you know things up and
running
so how do we really leverage that time
and and de-risk our investment when we
bring in emerging technology
you know it's just a methodology that
really we help our customers with to
consider not only the technology but how
does this impact the culture of the
company and how does this impact you
know the employees and and and the
processes and the way we operate today
you know so it's just a it's a
methodology to help companies kind of
work their way through bringing in new
solutions okay that's great and how
would you say is the number one way that
it actually helps those companies and
individuals achieve success do you have
a success story that you want to share
yeah so you know lots of them so
there's no such thing as a in the good
old days of technology of what we call
set and forget it just
setting up technology and letting it run
so we have our motto is all about like
failing fast or succeeding fast so it's
all about you know pivoting quickly and
moving fast and uh and just getting
results getting people within the
business so okay i understand where
we're going and it helps allow customers
to to just
get a quick gauge if they're on the
right path or not versus go through this
big
project that may not generate any
results at all for the business and how
do i really quantify that back to the
business am i really impacting a
business or is it just something nice to
have so it's you know that's really the
way we try to we track it and help them
become successful with it well thank you
so much jeff that is such great
information no matter what age you are
where you are who you are you need to
know how to evolve and transform
digitally
thank you so thank you to smg media
group for sponsoring that segment for
more information visit riverpoint
technology.com and we will be right back